STEPHANIE WONG: Today, we're
talking about C++, Dataflow,
and BigQuery.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We are now building C++ client
libraries for all Google Cloud
services.
Many of you are already using
the C++ libraries for Cloud
Storage and Bigtable.
And we hear your
requests for more.
We've just released a beta
version of the Cloud Spanner
C++ library.
And we're actively working on
open source client libraries
for all of the remaining
Cloud services.
Dataflow is Google Cloud's fully
managed batch and stream data
processing service.
And it now includes throughput
and CPU utilization charts
that will help you diagnose and
remediate your pipeline issues.
With better observability,
you can spend less time fixing
problems, and more time
getting value out of your data.
BigQuery is a serverless, highly
scalable, and cost effective
Cloud data warehouse.
It's designed to be flexible
and easy to use so that you make
a few decisions at the
start, and BigQuery
handles the work for you.
In this post, one
of our eng leads
explains how zone
assignments work in BigQuery
and covers best practices
for organizing your data.
Speaking of learning, we've
released the session guide
for Google Cloud Next 2020
in San Francisco on April 6th
through the 8th.
Registration is open now, and
you can even plan your journey
by checking out the over 500
sessions we will be offering.
Happy scrolling.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.